[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon message ce soir c'est que le pire
est derrière nous on a fait le plus dur
d'abord parce qu'on a vécu à mon avis
l'une pire des vagues de scoville depuis
deux ans même si on avait d'autres
vagues on a toutes les raisons de penser
que ce serait des virus des variants
moins dangereux ils vont aussi se
débarrasser du pass vaccinale ils la
verront l'a expliqué avec qui peuvent
ils eux dès qu'ils peuvent ils s'en
débarrassent ils savent comme nu qui se
sont plantés sur le pass vaccinale le
portefeuille des français se porte-t-il
bien cinq ans après l'élection d'
emmanuel macron pour 44% des sondés leur
situation économique personnelle s'est
détériorée depuis le début du
quinquennat
elle est pratique justice leur reproche
une centaine d'incidents le non respect
des horaires l'absence à des rendez vous
avec leur conseiller de probation ou
encore le non paiement d'acomptes qu'ils
doivent verser au fisc patrick balkany
aurait notamment été vue à plusieurs
reprises dans son ancien fief de
levallois à une heure où il aurait dû
être chez lui je me suis jamais fait de
la propriété gp jusqu'au portail où j'ai
été jusqu'à là à la grange et à chaque
fois fendu de trois personnes
reprocheront c'est d'autant plus idiot
entre guillemets ces dépassements que
isa l'est en mars ça allait s'arrêter il
était alors un mois il était un mois de
l'offre de leurs neuf mois de 2
bracelets la chambre d'application des
peines de la cour d'appel de rouen a
donc décidé d'incarcérer les époux
balkany qu'isabelle balkany a une
nouvelle fois tenté de mettre fin à ses
jours il ya quelque temps si peu de
temps après avoir appris la décision de
justice par ses avocats
et lui envoyer pas
qu'un commentaire non non je suis là
pour parler notamment de la situation
dans les ehpad et de la question du
grand âge jean marie 93 ans a été
hospitalisée hier soir le fondateur et
ancien président du front national avait
été victime d'un accident vasculaire
cérébral de portée minimale il devrait
sortir dans moins de 36 heures joe biden
justement dont les réformes sont menacés
à cause des problèmes de santé d'un
sénateur démocrate il a subi un accident
cardio-vasculaire ce qui a privé
temporairement le président des états
unis de sa majorité parlementaire qui ne
tient qu'à un fil macron il a peur de
quelque chose près d'un public peut pas
s'exonérer de cela il faut un débat moi
je dirais jupiter descente ton char un
peu nan sérieux coach nous avons la
nécessité d'un débat démocratique
donc le président de la république qui
va devenir maintenant candidat citoyens
et bien il faut qu'ils débattent avec
les autres candidats ah c'est pas normal
il doit parler avec tous les candidats
et débattre avec nous et devant les
français français musulmans dans leur
majorité je le répète ce que c'est une
évidence respecte les principes de la
république je parle de la ve vous l'avez
décidé ainsi
moi je ne vois que ce que je crois
marseille 5 114 kilos de drogue ont été
découverts sur l'un des bassins du grand
port maritime la semaine dernière à
l'arrivée d'un navire en provenance du
chili au milieu d'un chargement de
parquet on va sculpter avec des images
des images de kim jong-un sur son cheval
blanc
moi les par l'agencé officielle du
régime la cocaïne qui fait des ravages
en argentine au moins 20 personnes sont
mortes et 74 ont été hospitalisés en
banlieue de buenos aires après une
intoxication massive avec de la drogue
frelatée un communiqué de presse finale
oui c'est vraiment une petite pensée
pour le cheval